[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm KB HD here and
this is the Samsung Galaxy Note 3
successor to the galaxy note 2 and older
brother of the samsung galaxy s4 and
this is a phone that takes a little bit
from both to combine into a really
unique interesting Samsung flagship
device so first things first yes this is
a large device it has a 5.7 inch 1920 by
1080 AMOLED display but it's packed into
a body that's both thinner lighter and
narrower than the galaxy note 2 it fits
in its footprint and it has a larger
battery so when you consider all that
this one is actually more compact than
its predecessor but nevertheless it's a
bigger than average phone and that makes
it a two handed device for most people
but if you take a step back and look at
it this is a pretty interesting phone
aesthetically the front is the typical
Samsung squared-off look like the Galaxy
s4 has we're used to it plus the home
button in the middle on the front that
Samsung loves so much all around the
sides there's this silver metal band
that wraps all the way around and has
the buttons so your power button and
volume button I feel like they're a
little bit high up on the chassis I
don't think that people with smaller
hands are gonna like that it makes you
reach a little bit more but then again
you'll probably never press them
accidentally and up top you have your
headphone jack your microphone and the
IR blaster and out the bottom is a
smaller weaker speaker and the USB 3.0
port that I'll get to in a second it has
a removable back which reveals the
gigantic 3200 million power battery one
of the biggest and longest lasting in
any phone right now in fact it's about
the same size as the iPhones display by
itself and you can see the camera and
flash module the SIM card and SD card
readers and the stylus on the left hand
side the backing has an extremely subtle
curve on the edge to the center of the
back so that it doesn't rock on a table
and you set it down but it feels pretty
good when you're holding it in your hand
oh and a lot of people have been quick
to judge the way this phone looks
because it looks like leather and a lot
of people want to get their hands on
other phone but this is not leather this
is plastic that's shaped to look like it
feels like leather but it doesn't even
actually feel like leather it feels like
plastic because it's plastic so now that
we're not fooled by the aesthetic into
thinking this phone is crazy well-built
what's the deal with this USB 3.0
basically this is the first smartphone
to have a USB 3.0 port at the bottom
this allows for faster charging with
Samsung's cable and much faster data
transfer speeds if your computer
supports USB 3.0 but if you lose that
super ugly charger don't worry it's
still backwards compatible with USB 2.0
for all the same stuff anyway inside
this device is an absolutely ridiculous
spec list this is the octa-core version
here so it has a 1.9 gigahertz quad-core
processor and a one point three
gigahertz quad-core processor and it's
got three gigabytes of RAM so that would
lead you to believe that the Galaxy Note
3 is a monster performer and it is it
handles just about any application I
throw at it both regular and every day
and even heavy testing with just ease
it's graphic performance was smooth and
gaming responsive to my finger and
stylus input they were both fantastic
and scrolling around larger web pages
and heavy applications was smooth on
most devices you may have heard that
Samsung has been known to sort of ramp
up the CPU cores when it detects that
you're running a benchmark application
so I am done with showing benchmarks on
samsung devices but you can trust me not
only is this device fast but it shows
off how fast it is now I have hopes that
this kind of speed will stay with this
device for a much longer period of time
because this guy is running Android 4.3
the first version of Android to support
trim which is probably the most
underrated feature in this newest
version of jellybean but the bottom line
here is that the phone flies through
everything you'd expect it to and all
the same stuff that the Galaxy Note 2
and galaxy s4 fly through also but the
Galaxy Note 3 has some tricks up its
sleeve and it packs some new unique
features that make this more than just a
spec bump upgrade from the note 2 and no
I'm not talking about an extra color
option or anything like that this is
part of the note line so a big deal with
this device is this stylus the note 3
stylus is
redesigned from the one in the note to
so it's a little more square it fits in
the phone upside down or right side up
it can also now click the capacitive
menu and back keys on either side of the
home button and it comes with some new
software features built into the phone
to make it more useful but less
obtrusive so now when you take the phone
out you take the stylus out of the phone
while the screen is on or off you'll get
a small circular window that pops up
with the most commonly used touch with
stylus features that you can hover over
to read and then single tap on for easy
access I'm not a huge stylus user myself
but when I do use the stylus when I
actually take it out the phone I usually
know exactly what I want to do with it
so the pop-up window actually made it
really quick and easy to get the stuff
done that I wanted to get done now
there's another feature in the Galaxy
Note 3 that Samsung insists on including
in every new Galaxy device and that's s
voice and it's of course present here on
the Galaxy Note 3 it's still not that
great it's still not even close to Siri
or Google now but they've added another
feature for the Galaxy Note 3 where you
can interact with it while the display
is still off sort of like the way you
can on the Moto X with the Moto X you
would say ok Google now because it uses
Google now but since this uses s voice
it responds to high Galaxy weather
uh-huh anytime all right there there we
go so now it's got the weather it
doesn't speak anything back to you but
it does give you a couple of limited
options for information or if you want
to text or call someone it'll do that
but you know it's not even close to
Google now now despite everything else
that was awesome about this phone on the
inside it is still a Samsung device
which means it's still running TouchWiz
on top of Android if you guys know me
well you already know I prefer stock
Android over any sort of skin version of
Android like this but touch weighs still
has its faults it still has occasional
jank it still has the occasional hiccup
and weird stutter that it really
shouldn't have on a device with awesome
specs like this but I don't want to make
it sound like Samsung skin is all
garbage because it's not there are some
features that I actually really like in
it
I like the Flipboard power to my
magazine app that can pop up from the
bottom of the screen and aggregates all
your social news kind of like blinkfeed
on the HTC One I like having the quick
toggles above the notification bar and
the immediately available brightness
toggle that's something I've gotten used
to having I also like the multi window
feature and how much better it's getting
with every update I mean at this point
you can have two apps running in the
background and one overtop of all of
them I mean you can multitask in your
multitasking wall multitasking okay it's
it's pretty awesome
I mean it's just obvious that Samsung
through every single possible feature
they could into this device just like
they did with the galaxy s4 everything
but the kitchen sink in hopes that
something will get you to like it enough
to buy it
a familiar strategy but using the Galaxy
Note 3 there are two major things that I
notice are the biggest improvements over
the note 2 one is the display it's a 5.7
inch 1080p display so that gives a super
sharp pixel intensity of 386 pixels per
inch and it's an AMOLED display and it's
not a pentile matrix and it gets super
bright and has great viewing angles it's
super sensitive and it gets almost
edge-to-edge on the display so it's not
quite edge to edge but it's easily one
of the best screens on any mobile phone
right alongside the LG g2 and the HTC
One top of the class and it's easily the
note 3's best physical asset the other
is the camera the note 3 is outfitted
with a new
13 megapixel camera and you'll probably
recognize that from the galaxy s4 so
you'd expect the pictures to look about
the same way as the galaxy s4 pictures
do but they don't there's some very
updated image processing going on with
the galaxy note 3 some very aggressive
sharpening some noise reduction and they
almost make the shots look a little bit
over sharpened and over processed which
is a look that some people like and
it'll work with some shots but it's not
always my favorite I'll leave a gallery
of the full-size test shots that I took
in the link right below that like button
so if you want to check them out
basically the full-size tops will get
you a better idea of how they look I
think the pictures of thing takes are in
a league of their own it's super fun to
shoot with especially because the
viewfinder is that whole 5.7 inch
display and the performance in regular
light is pretty stellar dynamic range is
pretty good and sharpness like we say
with that 13 megapixel sensor is quite
good but you can check all that out for
yourself and in terms of video mode the
Snapdragon 800 version of the Galaxy
Note 3 that'll be sold in the United
States will shoot 4k Ultra High
Definition video so that is just
insanely sharp you'll probably never be
able to share with anyone who will be
able to watch it in native 4k but I
mentioned earlier that I would have
liked to have seen optical image
stabilization in the note 3's camera to
smooth out that 4k video but that's
about the only downside to the camera so
when you think about it a lot of the
note 3's best features besides the
stylus functionality come from the
Galaxy s4 so it'll keep being this way
as long as the Galaxy S line is updated
before the Galaxy Note line every year
so you'd want to make sure the notes
advantages over the s4 are very clear
and very strong right now these
advantages are the stylus that the s4
doesn't have the larger display and
slightly more RAM and more power and the
much larger battery and I think that's
the kicker right now that's my favorite
advantage the huge battery I mentioned
earlier that the Galaxy Note 3 here
packs a 3,200 milliamp hour battery and
it kicks ass all day every day the
Galaxy Note 3 is a reliable all-day
driver it got me
somewhere in the ballpark of 5 hours of
screen on time with very heavy use this
is the same sort of use that got me less
than 4 hours with the galaxy s4 so this
is pretty impressive stuff as defin
truly an all-day phone so I guess what
I'm saying here is I like this phone I
like a lot of things about this phone
one of the hardest things to do when
picking a new device is changing a
screen size by a drastic amount but once
you go big you never really go back once
you get used to have a phone with the
display like this you'll never look at
the smaller devices the same way again I
can guarantee you that the note 3 is one
of those phones that isn't revolutionary
and it isn't obviously the best phone
out there or anything like that but it's
pretty damn good in every single
department that could possibly make a
phone good it's not perfect it has it's
quartz it's definitely not perfect it
has the weird plastic backing material
it still has its settings menu that is
so messed up that Samsung decided to
throw in a search box I mean it's
definitely not perfect but you could
almost not care when you hop into your
favorite applications and see how much
more space you have and how much more
smoothly they run the experience is what
really matters and this is an awesome
experience device in conclusion the
Galaxy Note 3 is one of my favorite
phones of 2013 and it's gonna be really
difficult to move from a smaller device
like I was using before like the Moto X
to something like this but again we've
talked about this before I easily get
used to a device like this I came from
something the size of a Galaxy Note 2 so
this isn't really all that big feeling
in my hands and a lot of people who have
been using a big device like this will
say the same thing it looks really big
at first but once you get used to using
it it feels like a totally normal sized
phone that being said that's about it
for this review of the galaxy note 3 if
you have any questions at all feel free
to leave a comment right below that like
button and speaking of the like button
do feel free to hit that thumbs up it
helps us out a lot here thank you so
much for watching and I will talk to you
guys in the next video peace
[Music]